No, Ukraine isn't fake.
Hi, my name is Benoît. I make videos
about history, especially the
parts that people lie about.
Today we're tackling
something truly absurd.
The idea that Ukraine isn't real, that
it's a fake country, a Nazi
invention, a Western puppet,
all myths that are pushed by the Russian
state to justify a brutal invasion.
But history tells a different story. One,
Russia is desperate to erase.
Let's start with a basic fact.
Ukraine is not a recent invention.
The idea of Ukraine and of Ukrainians as
a people is hundreds of years old.
In medieval times, the powerful Kievan
Rus was centered in what's now Kiev.
Yeah, that Kiev, the one that Russia is
bombing with missiles.
Kievan Rus wasn't
Russian in the modern sense.
It was a multi-ethnic federation with
deep Slavic roots and
Orthodox Christianity.
And it's claimed today by modern Russia,
Belarus and also Ukraine.
In reality, it was closer to Ukraine,
geographically,
culturally and politically,
than anything we'd call Russia today.
The Primary Chronicle, written around
1113, a foundational
text of the Kievan Rus,
places Kiev as the political and
spiritual heart of the region.
Not Novgorod or Moscow,
which didn't even exist yet.
Moscow didn't even appear in written
records until the 1147 Chronicle,
centuries after Kiev was
already a major center.
And when Moscow did emerge, it
wasn't the heir to Kievan Rus,
but one of several French principalities
scrambling for power under Mongol rule.
The myth of Moscow as the Third Rome, the
rightful successor to
Byzantium and the Rus,
was political branding by the Moskowitz
Church and State in the 15th century, not
historical continuity.
The letters of Philateus, written in the
16th century,
proclaimed Moscow the Third Rome.
This was ideological myth-making,
designed to legitimize the Moskowitz rule
after the fall of Constantinople, just as
it was claimed by the Holy Roman Empire.
For centuries after the fall of Kievan
Rus, the lands of modern Ukraine were
split between empires.
Polish, Lithuanian,
Ottoman, Habsburg and Russian.
But Ukrainian identity survived, in
songs, in language and religion,
in the way people spoke about
their land, not someone else's.
In the 1600s, a semi-independent
Cossack-Hetmanate
rose in central Ukraine.
Orthodox, militarized and fiercely
autonomous, the Cossacks
signed treaties with Polish kings
and later aligned with the Moskowitz to
protect their religious freedom.
It was never a total submission.
The 1654 Treaty of Perislav, often cited
by Russian historians as
proof of Ukraine joining Russia,
was more like an alliance,
conditional and contested.
The articles of Perislav outlined
specific Cossack demands for autonomy,
many of which were
later ignored by Moscow,
sparking uprisings like the Helmenitsky
Rebellion and the later Masepa Revolt.
By the 18th century, the Hetmanate was
dismantled and fully
absorbed into the Russian Empire,
but Ukrainian identity didn't vanish.
Ukrainian intellectuals, often working in
secret, kept the culture alive.
That is, Sefchenko, born into Serfdom,
became the voice of a people.
His 1840s collection, Kopsar, was banned
by Tsarist authorities, yet
it circulated underground.
His poems were not just
literature, they were a declaration.
We exist.
Sefchenko's poem, "My Testament," became
a national rallying cry.
It was recited at funerals, protests and
eventually independence rallies.
When I am dead, bury me
In a grave
Among the wide steppe
In my beloved Ukraine
In 1917, the Russian Empire collapses and
Ukraine declares independence.
For a brief window, there was a real
Ukrainian state, the
Ukrainian People's Republic.
It had a government, embassies and a
military, even its own
currency and postage stamps.
The UPR issued its own banknotes and
treaties, such as the 1918 Treaty of
Brest-Litovsk, signed
with central powers,
and was recognized de
facto by several states.
The Republic was short-lived, it was
crushed by the Bolsheviks
during the Russian Civil War.
The Red Army invaded Kiev multiple times
between 1918 and 1921.
Still, this idea of a
sovereign Ukraine didn't vanish.
Underground movements, cultural societies
and partisan forces kept it alive even
after the Republic fell.
When Ukraine declared independence again
in 1991, it wasn't inventing a country,
it was restoring one.
There is a myth pushed very hard by Putin
that Ukraine only exists because of
Lenin, that it was
created by the Soviet Union.
But that's not just
wrong, it's propaganda.
The truth is, Ukraine declared
independence on its own, was crushed by
force and then absorbed into a Soviet
structure designed to control it.
Lenin's 1919 letter, "The Question of
Nationalities or Autonomization", reveals
his concern about
great Russian chauvinism.
But his solution wasn't independence, it
was tighter Soviet integration under the
appearance of equality.
The Ukrainian Soviet Socialist Republic
was not freedom, it was a mask.
Over the next decades, Ukrainian culture
and autonomy were
systematically dismantled.
One of the most horrific moments came
during the Holodomor, Stalin's man-made
famine of 1932-1933, which killed an
estimate of 3-4 million Ukrainians.
US reports from 1933, now declassified,
describe entire
villages starving to death.
Soviet archives confirm forced grain
requisitions and the sealing of
international borders to prevent escape.
Even after the famine repression
continued, Ukrainian language schools
were closed, books were banned, artists
and intellectuals were purged in the
1930s and again in the 1970s.
Recification wasn't just
policy, it was a war on identity.
The 1972 arrest of poet Vasyl Sturs for
anti-Soviet agitation is one of many, his
crime, writing poems in Ukrainian and
advocating for cultural freedom.
So why does Russia
say Ukraine isn't real?
Because acknowledging Ukrainian statehood
threatens the entire
mythology of Russian imperialism.
The idea that Russia is the natural
center of all Slavs, that it's entitled
to dominate its neighbors, that it must
protect Russians
everywhere, even if it means invasion.
This isn't new, but it's been weaponized
with renewed intensity since 2014, or
some people would argue, 2008, when
Russian troops went into Georgia.
In his 2021 essay on the historical unity
of Russians and Ukrainians, Vladimir
Putin claimed that Russians and
Ukrainians are one people, and that true
Ukrainian sovereignty is only possible in
partnership with Russia.
He openly blames Lenin for ever allowing
Ukraine to exist at all.
This isn't about
history, it's about control.
In Putin's worldview, shaped by thinkers
like Ivan Ilyin, a Russian immigrant
fascist who's worked Putin frequently
cites, Ukraine is an error that must be
corrected, even by force.
Ilyin's writings, revived in the 2000s by
Putin's administration, stress national
unity through spiritual authoritarianism.
He viewed federalism and Ukrainian
independence as
threats to Russian greatness.
Putin isn't reviving the USSR, he is
reviving the Tsarist empire, one where
Ukraine doesn't exist.
But Ukraine does exist.
It exists in blood, in culture, in
memory, in centuries of resistance, from
the Cossack Uprising to Sefshenko's
poetry, to the defenders of Kiev today.
It exists in the songs banned by the
Tsars, in the grain fields where millions
starved, but didn't break.
In the voices of poets like Lina
Kostenko, who wrote on her Soviet rule,
"Nations do not die from gunfire, but
from the loss of memory."
And memory in Ukraine has always
survived. No missile, no
lie, no empire will erase that.
Thanks for watching. If you found this
valuable, consider
liking, subscribing and sharing.
This kind of history isn't always
thought, but it's always worth knowing.
Sources are linked in the description.
Thank you very much for listening.